[Musica]
per chi di voi non fosse appassionato di
cinematografia o per chi dovesse aver
vissuto su marte negli ultimi 38 anni
quello che avete appena visto è il
monologo finale di un film del regista
americano ridley scott del 1982 peraltro
mio anno di nascita
finché è stato in grado di trascendere
tempo e spazio e differenze
generazionali e divenire un pilastro
della cultura pop mondiale mag la rai è
un film che rimane nel mondo non perché
il regista bravissimo gli attori ancor
più eccezionale abbiamo visto power ma
perché tutte le volte che lo vediamo ci
sentiamo un pochino male è una sorta di
disagio che sentiamo distintamente e di
cui tuttavia non possiamo fare a meno
perché origina da una domanda che
risuona in ognuno di noi
una domanda che è in grado di mettere in
discussione tutto ciò che sappiamo o
pensiamo di sapere sull'esistenza e
questa domanda è ma gli androidi sognano
pecore elettriche lo so per molti di voi
questa domanda è totalmente priva di
senso per odio androids dream of
electric sheep è il titolo del romanzo
dell'autore americano file che i tech
che dà origine al mito di black swan di
che percorre gli stessi passi di autori
come isaac asimov ma prende la
letteratura sei fai e la porta a nuovi
orizzonti orizzonti post moderni post
umani e post umanistici essenzialmente
di che crea il movimento cyberpunk un
universo distopico in cui la grande
evoluzione tecnologica ridefinisce le
dinamiche e le gerarchie sociali in cui
la tecnologia mette in discussione
essenzialmente il ruolo del uomo al
centro del mondo
il nostro umanesimo l'umanesimo appunto
è con la prospettiva ma per cui l'uomo
si sostituisce a dio rifiutando e
diventa centro del tutto grazie alla sua
capacità di logica il suo intelletto e
alla sua capacità di empatizzare con ciò
che ci circonda
nel suo libro e nel film il regista è
l'autore ci chiedono
cosa c'è di così particolare nell'uomo
da porlo al centro del tutto e chi
presenta un futuro oscuro e senza sole
dove piove sempre come unico rimedio per
constrastare l'insostenibile
inquinamento atmosferico in cui uomini
android e convivono in cui l'egemonia
culturale politica e asiatica in questo
mondo l'intelligenza artificiale ha
sostituito l'elettricità alla base di
una nuova rivoluzione economica e
sociale e l'uomo compie grazie alla
tecnologia un ulteriore slittamento nel
suo ruolo del tutto dopo essersi
sostituito a dio diviene egli stesso dio
e creatore di una genia di esseri
artificiali gli androidi appunto
costruiti e creati a propria immagine e
somiglianza con lo scopo di superare la
limitatezza dell'uomo gli android sono
più belli intelligenti più forti degli
uomini ma l'uomo deve comunque
conservare il proprio centro nel mondo e
quindi li crea con una vita molto molto
breve con la giustificazione che la
fiamma che brilla al doppio della
luminosità brucia in metà tempo alcuni
androidi però si ribellano e decidono di
mischiarsi agli uomini per cercare di
incontrare proprio creatore per chiedere
di vivere un pochettino in più si rimane
si rende quindi necessaria chiedere
quale sia la differenza tra uomini e
android
la domanda dell'autore diventa ancor più
evidente cos'è che ci differenzia queste
che ci dà il diritto di porci comunque
al centro del mondo
soprattutto adesso che logica intelletto
e forza fisica
sono degli androidi la risposta è il
gold camp test in test del tutto
fittizio che serve per determinare se un
soggetto esaminato è in grado di provare
empatia con ciò che lo circonda
l'empatia quindi diventa ciò che
veramente ci distingue è una sorta di
upgrade del cogito ergo sum cartesiano
penso quindi sono che ha sostituito da
aifi del foyer ma io sento quindi sono
umano è degno di vivere e non è un caso
che il protagonista il nome del
protagonista sia una trasposizione
letterale di rené descartes cioè di
cartesio
la cosa incredibile all'interno del film
e del libro è che a un certo punto
considerando che gli androidi riescono a
provare empatia avete visto eroi salva
ric
alla fine noi ci troviamo impattare con
gli androidi e quasi a desiderare che
come noi ci siamo sostituiti a dio
loro si sostituiscano a noi che siamo il
loro dio perché vi ho raccontato questa
storia e perché adesso perché nonostante
manchino ancora sono un po di anni alla
realizzarsi di questo tipo di futuro
la traiettoria verso cui sembriamo
essere direzionati sembra abbastanza
segnata consideriamo una legge
fondamentale dell'information
communication technology
la legge di moore legge di moore dice
che ogni due anni la capacità
computazionale delle macchine raddoppia
in una società che si basa così
endemicamente nella sulla tecnologia se
ogni due anni l'ha capita computazionale
delle macchine raddoppia la distanza che
ci separa dal nostro futuro ogni due
anni di mezza la realtà è che
l'intelligenza artificiale esista già
sostituendo l'elettricità e presto noi
dovremmo shiftare da una programmazione
per un profitto alla creazione per un
valore facciamo passi dietro quando noi
pensiamo all'intelligenza artificiale
probabilmente pensiamo a un computer che
gioca a scacchi e batte il campione del
mondo di scacchi quel computer era di
blu di ai pm quel campione del mondo di
scacchi a ragazzi kasparov e l'anno era
il 1997 che in er tecnologica è come
dire la preistoria
vediamo cosa succede cosa successe in
questi ultimi anni nel 2016 un algoritmo
intelligenza artificiale sconfigge il
campione del mondo dico ok il gioco
considerato l'epitome dell'intelletto
umano
un trio re e triglione i trilioni di
combinazioni superiore al gioco di scala
per cui un trilione di trilioni di
trilioni di volte più difficile del
gioco di scacchi questo algoritmo gioca
contro se stesso per un paio d'ore va
contro il campione del mondo e lo batte
utilizzando delle tecniche assolutamente
incomprensibile a noi nel 2016
oplà perbene xvi impariamo la parità
uomo macchina cioè la macchina riesce a
riconoscere gli oggetti altrettanto bene
rispetto agli uomini
nel 2017 la voice recognition le
macchine comprendono la voce esattamente
come noi questo le turbine 17 tre anni
fa nel 2018 anno la stessa accuratezza
nel rispondere alle domande nel 2019
riescono a tradurre tutti i migliaia di
dialetti del cinese in inglese
altrettanto bene quindi mi sembra logico
che la logica appunto nell'intelletto
siano stati bocciati o quanto almeno
addirittura alcuni casi superati cosa
resta gli uomini parte ovviamente vero
gara chi è la poetessa più seguita del
mondo
oggi la protesta più seguita del mondo
con oltre 700 milioni di lettori e ciao
ice un intelligenza per gradito vita
artificiale
microsoft che non solo scrive ma conduce
7 programmi televisivi e canta anche
delle canzoni un altro bellissimo
progetto sempre parte chiara è il the
next rembrandt project che nel 2017 ha
visto un intelligenza artificiale sempre
di microsoft studiare tutti i capolavori
di rembrandt in modo approfondito
poi l'abbiamo collegato l'anno collegato
ad una stampante 3d e da solo
abbiamo lasciato libero di esprimersi ha
creato un nuovo dipinto un nuovo dipinto
che tutti gli esperti del mondo di
rembrandt avrebbero attribuito la grande
pittore fiammingo
ovviamente oggi sapete che il 95 per
cento del valore di tutto ciò che noi
consideriamo di valore il valore
attribuito su un
praticamente l'operazione semantica il
riconoscimento di un simbolo e
l'attribuzione di un significato che è
fatta da un uomo
la verità abad e voi cosa è successo
quel quadro non l'abbiamo mai saputo
però so ma c'è da qualche parte la
verità che l'intelligenza artificiale
esista già come abbiamo detto
sostituendo l'elettricità e come negli
anni sessanta e settanta le catene di
montaggio sono state automatizzate i
nostri lavori o parte i nostri lavori
però i più spersonalizzanti verranno
automatizzate questo sono le richieste
di intelligenza artificiale
quindi ci troviamo a chiedere cosa è il
nostro posto nel mondo quale cosa ct
termina al centro del mondo
ancora una volta la nostra empatia
determinerà il nostro posto il tipo di
futuro è utopico distopico magari più
giusto la verità che in questo momento
abbiamo la possibilità di correggere gli
errori
attraverso le perché di capire la
creazione per un valore verso quale
valore creare ma come sta la nostra
empatia
ultimamente c'è un piccolo esperimento
iniziamo a pensare di avere un algoritmo
l'intelligenza artificiale e gli diciamo
abbiamo un'azienda assumi i migliori
professionisti in assoluto gli diamo
tutti i dati di tutte le aziende del
mondo della storia dell'economia con
tutti i dati di tutti i professionisti
del mondo della storia dell'economia
visto che l'intelligenza artificiale e
la qualità dell'output dipende dal
valore del dato e dalla bontà del dato
quello che oggi questa questa
intelligenza artificiale ha prodotto
produrrebbe è un uomo di 40 anni bianco
perché ovviamente nella storia siamo
soggetti a un sacco di preconcetti di
discriminazioni di pay gap
quindi vi chiedo come il nostro stato
impanti empatico in questo momento il
nostro sostegno sovranista oggi è a due
punti percentuali sotto quello che era
nel 1839 vi ricorda qualcosa
nel 1939 qual è il percorso su cui ci
muoviamo
siamo un mondo che costruisce muri che
le aiuta a casa loro che rilascia sui
balconi del superman del mediterraneo
che mette per ma gli italiani ferma gli
americani prima gli inglesi siamo un
mondo molto distopico quindi il futuro
non può che essere distopico la cosa
perversa e che abbiamo smesso di creare
e di cercare in praticamente un valore
ma cerchiamo di confermare i nostri byas
come se fosse juventus inter una cosa di
puro tifo di puro credo lei fake muse
sono all'esplosione e questo non è un
piccolissimo dettaglio questo
corrisponde ad un impennata time della
discriminazione
e questo il futuro che vogliamo stephen
hawking ci dice che siamo sul rischio di
distruggere la nostra razza umana la
nostra umanità a causa della nostra
abilità e della nostra stupidità
quindi siamo fregati e pre o poi saremmo
stupiti dalla macchina no perché c'è
anche chi fortunatamente la pensa in
modo diverso e fa in modo diverso
qualcuna prima ha detto per essere
bisogna fare sono assolutamente
d'accordo bayern su action un esempio e
microsoft che anche il motivo per cui io
sono entrato in microsoft cioè la
visione umanistica della tecnologia e
dell'intelligenza artificiale usata per
dare più potere twinpower aree peep a
superare le limitazioni a superare le
discriminazioni ve ne do un esempio
[Musica]
è un nostro collega intelligenza
artificiale bisogno di qualcuno che le
riunioni cresce lettieri venuti a vedere
davanti a questo questo utilizzo
correggere gli errori
hanine questo è qualcosa che vale la
pena esplorare tutti i migliori
un altro esempio è lineare project un
algoritmo che è stato fatto col tumore
all'occhio col tumore al seno
col tumore al pancreas che aumenta del
95 per cento la capacità era quel caso
il 99 per cento di diagnosticare
correttamente una massa tumorale
ovviamente non sto assolutamente
suggerendo che questa cosa che
l'intelligenza artificiale debba
sostituirsi ai medici non è
assolutamente così però per quanto
riguarda l'immagine king aragon nation
sicuramente questo è più preciso quindi
liberando il medico le sue capacità
cognitive almeno una parte di questo
peso
oggi il medico può occuparsi di quello
che più importante sulla gestione del
paziente
la gestione della persona che ha davanti
questo è solo uno dei tantissimi esempi
che che esistono degli esempi virtuosi
però essenzialmente la domanda che vi
faccio che dipende da noi come quello
che vorrei che capissimo non dipende
solo da noi e quindi vi chiedo ma sarà
il caso che anche non iniziamo a sognare
piccole elettriche grazie
[Applauso]